[Applauso]
ma cosa pensate se vi dico buono nel
concreto può riferirsi alle cose buono
quindi come prelibato come un piatto di
pasta ben condito una vera mozzarella di
bufala campana artigianale o buona come
vantaggioso un investimento redditizio
un risultato raggiunto con dedizione o
può chiaramente riferirsi all'etica un
animo buono fare una donazione un buon
amico
insomma buono come antitesi del cattivo
è facile tutti siamo in grado di
giudicare quando qualcosa è buono
più difficile è vedere il buono che
ancora non c'è
il buono in forme idee ancora poco
esplorate o il buono in situazioni
quotidiane ma non scontato io qualche
anno fa a 32 anni ho ritrovato il buono
nella mia terra di nascita che avete
capito e la campania
dico ritrovato perché decisi di tornare
sui miei passi che in precedenza mi
avevano visto alla ricerca altrove di un
affermazione professionale tornato con
la consapevolezza di poter trovare a
distanza di anni gli stimoli giusti per
unire il mio senso civico alla necessità
di un lavoro
onesto gratificante e potenzialmente
determinante per le sorti del mio
territorio e fino a qualche anno fa
credetemi non era possibile trovare del
buono nella mia terra perché in campania
come in molte altre parti d'italia i
nostri territori sono stati per troppo
tempo violentati e deturpati della
propria bellezza e della propria civiltà
le mafie si le mafie hanno
spadroneggiato gli hanno fatto sfacelo
in alcuni di noi hanno provocato rabbia
e indignazione in altri solo passiva
rassegnazione o peggio ancora
indifferenza in molte parti d'italia
quindi le mafie nell'indifferenza e
nella paura con violenza e corruzione
hanno accumulato ricchezze a spese della
collettività ea spese della nostra terra
acquisendo potere fino ad espandere il
loro traffici a carattere nazionale e
addirittura internazionale e chiaro
ormai che nessuno può e deve sentirsi
escluso da questi argomenti è nostro è
vostro dovere comprendere pienamente il
potere delle mafie e le sue modalità di
consenso perché chi ha pensato e
continuo a pensare alle mafie ea sistemi
corruttivi come problemi che non
riguardano tutti che non investono tutti
noi continua ad esserne
involontariamente
complice in italia ci abbiamo messo un
po a rendercene conto
immaginate che fino al 1982 nonostante
si parlasse di mafia da tantissimi anni
fino all 82 non esisteva una legge che
prevedesse il reato di associazione a
delinquere di stampo mafioso né la
possibilità di sequestrare e confiscare
i patrimoni accumulati illegalmente dai
mafiosi e fino al 1996 non esisteva una
legge che prevedesse il riuso sociale
dei beni sequestrati e confiscati ai
mafiosi che perlopiù restavano uno stato
di tristissimo abbandono la legge 109
approvate in parlamento nel marzo del
1996 è una legge di iniziativa popolare
promossa da libera associazioni nomi e
numeri contro le mafie al cui sostegno
furono raccolte più di un milione di
firme e da questa intuizione da questa
visione positiva da questa voglia di
riscatto che nel 2001 in sicilia nasce
il progetto libera terra per iniziativa
dell'associazione libera e che oggi
raggruppa varie cooperative sociali nate
grazie alla selezione dei soci tramite
bando pubblico che operano oltre che in
sicilia da dove tutto è nato anche in
puglia in calabria e in campania in
territori quindi difficili complicati ma
di rara bellezza
io sono orgogliosamente il presidente di
una di queste cooperative le terre di
don peppe diana libera terra
don peppino diana era un sacerdote di
casal di principe che venne ammazzato
all'interno della sua chiesa il 19 marzo
del 1994 punito a morte per il suo
impegno che potremmo sintetizzare dal
titolo di un documento di suo pugno che
lui diffuse nel territorio qualche anno
prima per amore del mio popolo non
tacerò
quindi con il progetto libera terra
noi vogliamo dimostrare quale valore e
importanza possono avere per un
territorio percorsi di riutilizzo
sociale di beni confiscati e libera
terra e anche il marchio che trovate su
prodotti provenienti dal lavoro di soci
e dipendenti di cooperative sociali che
lavorano su terreni e impianti
confiscati ad esponenti della malavita
organizzata
l'obiettivo principale quindi è
indebolire in modo essenziale le
organizzazioni criminali riducendo i
loro confini
sottraendo i loro patrimoni e
riqualificandoli il nostro lavoro arriva
dopo lo svolgimento del dovere da parte
delle istituzioni magistratura e forze
dell'ordine e quindi ora i beni che
rappresentavano la forza e il dominio
criminale possono diventare occasioni di
sviluppo e crescita dei sistemi
economici e sociali in netta
discontinuità con i sistemi mafiosi
a guidarci nel nostro percorso
abbiamo tre valori fondamentali qualità
sostenibilità e memoria qualità intesa
in termini concreti ed etici perché la
nostra attività
e produttiva agricola alimentare i
nostri luoghi di lavoro sono i terreni
agricoli confiscati e convertiti e
metodi di produzione biologica per
ottenere prodotti di alta qualità che
siano rispettosi dell'ambiente e della
dignità delle persone coinvolte tutto
obbligatoriamente deve essere curato con
la massima attenzione
gestiamo beni dello stato
ogni step delle nostre filiere
produttive costantemente monitorato per
assicurare prodotti che congiuntamente
al loro valore etico sociale abbiano una
qualità riconoscibile che tenda
all'eccellenza per questo svolgiamo il
nostro lavoro con la massima trasparenza
per rendere concreto visibile
accessibile e comprensibile il nostro
impegno quotidiano
poi vogliamo che il bene che creiamo sia
sostenibile sia dal punto di vista
economico ma anche dal punto di vista
ambientale
pensiamo che il modo giusto conveniente
e vincente di fare economia oggi sia
quello animato dal vivere
l'etica d'impresa con integrità e
corresponsabilità alle sorti dei nostri
territori e del nostro intero paese
in netta contrapposizione quindi con
l'economia criminale e il suo
sistematico disprezzo delle regole
vogliamo creare quindi un impatto
positivo proponendo un sistema economico
basato su legalità
giustizia sociale e mercato vogliamo
generare filiere di produzioni eque e un
sistema di economia partecipata
coinvolgendo altri imprenditori che
agiscono i nostri stessi campi d'azione
un modello che si sostenga con le
proprie gambe
facciamo del bene non beneficenza dal
punto di vista ambientale
pensiamo che la tutela del proprio
habitat dovrebbe essere la normalità
come normale dovrebbe essere sinonimo di
legale perché il rispetto delle leggi in
un paese civile questo dovrebbe sempre
rappresentare la difesa dell'ambiente e
perciò una priorità in termini assoluti
nella cura e nella preservazione del
bene comune perché i beni confiscati
sono bene comune l'idea di sposare
metodi di agricoltura sostenibile è
insita nella stessa mission di libera
terra il rispetto dell'ambiente potremmo
dire che la nostra prima forma di
legalità possibile e infine a guidarci
c'è la memoria è nostra responsabilità
ricordare tutte le vittime innocenti che
le mafie hanno provocato nel nostro
paese sono quasi mille le nostre
cooperative i nostri prodotti sono
quindi spesso dedicate alla memoria di
morti innocenti per colpa delle mafie
una memoria che abbiamo il dovere di
conservare alimentare nomi e storie che
siamo tenuti a ricordare
e a onorare perché purtroppo ancora oggi
chiedono ancora verità e giustizia
qualcuno diceva non siamo la memoria che
abbiamo noi siamo alla memoria che
abbiamo è la responsabilità che ci
assumiamo senza memoria non esistiamo e
senza responsabilità non meritiamo di
esistere
e allora il valore della memoria per
come lo sentiamo addosso per come lo
viviamo si tramuta direttamente in
impegno un impegno assiduo volto
all'affermazione delle nostre imprese
con attività che sono il mezzo per il
raggiungimento dei nostri scopi sociali
che il vero fine della nostra mission
l'inserimento lavorativo di persone
svantaggiate con piccole disabilità che
non gli impediscono di essere attivi
operativi all'interno delle delle nostre
filiere di produzione e più in generale
la creazione di nuove opportunità per
tutti coloro che nei nostri territori
sono nati e vogliono continuare a
viverci a rendersi disponibili per
percorsi di riscatto come quelli che noi
cerchiamo di rappresentare e proprio per
la qualità la sostenibilità e la memoria
se oggi siamo in tanti ad aver
recuperato la fiducia verso le
possibilità di costruire un futuro
libero dalle mafie libera terra in 17
anni di attività ormai ha creato tante
opportunità professionali per tante
persone soprattutto giovani che vedono
finalmente una concreta prospettiva di
sviluppo e di successo imprenditoriale
senza essere costretti ad abbandonare la
propria terra oa scendere a compromessi
con i propri principi etici e io sono
uno di loro
oggi con il mio lavoro insieme agli
altri soci della cooperativa che
rappresento contribuisco ad alimentare
la speranza che è possibile per i
giovani meridionali
una vera alternativa non ci piace essere
definiti degli eroi delle persone
particolarmente coraggiose siamo persone
assolutamente normali
ci assumiamo i rischi d'impresa
soprattutto mettendoci la faccia
svolgendo corresponsabilità ogni giorno
nel nostro dovere di cooperatori siamo
persone che lavorano quindi con orgoglio
con passione con entusiasmo per
prenderci cura dei beni che ci vengono
assegnati dalle istituzioni con la
volontà di realizzare il nostro
potenziale professionale e insieme
contribuire a consolidare una nuova
coscienza collettiva attraverso un modo
nuovo di fare impresa che prima non
esisteva perché le nostre sono imprese a
tutti gli effetti non sono occasionali
raccolte fondi
noi non vogliamo che qualcuno scelga e
compri i nostri prodotti per darci
assistenza vogliamo che il marchio
libera terra sulla nostra pasta sulle
nostre mozzarelle di bufala indichi
chiaramente che sono prodotti buoni
buoni non solo perché strumenti di
riscatto e di ridefinizione
dell'identità delle nostre terre
ma buoni perché di qualità e di
eccellenza
una qualità è un'eccellenza che vogliamo
siano pari al valore etico di cui questi
prodotti sono portatori in molte parti
d'italia quindi dicevamo per troppo
tempo le mafie hanno spadroneggiato
sulle nostre terre calpestando il buono
che queste contenevano in italia ci
abbiamo messo troppo tempo a rendercene
conto
ma oggi nei terreni confiscati alle
mafie
un'intera comunità di persone lavora
perché queste terre producano qualcosa
di buono ci abbiamo messo un po ma ora
non possiamo più tergiversare non
possiamo più rimandare il momento in cui
potremmo affermare ad alta voce che si è
voltato pagina che mafie e sistemi
corruttivi rappresentano il passato sono
il passato è dovere di tutti noi
comprendere pienamente oggi il
potenziale potere dell'antimafia sociale
e le sue modalità di partecipazione
civile
un giorno lo speriamo tutti le mafie non
esisteranno più
ma dovranno continuare ad esistere
i prodotti frutto del lavoro buono
pulito e giusto
prodotti che provengono dai patrimoni
che erano delle mafie ma soprattutto che
sono grati nati grazie a un sistema
imprenditoriale etico e cooperativo un
sistema che fa del bene che promuove il
rilancio sociale che crea qualità
eccellenza e valore economico un sistema
buono che si sosterrà
e continuerà a prosperare ne siamo
convinti anche quando le mafie saranno
soltanto un ricordo lontano
[Applauso]